my first guest tonight is stephen
wertheim a senior fellow at the american
statecraft program at the carnegie
endowment for international peace
he's also
an author of the book tomorrow the world
the birth of u.s global supremacy
stephen it's good to have you on the
program tonight
we saw what happened
yesterday we had ukrainian russian
negotiators sitting down in turkey
talking about possible ways to get to
peace today moscow saying that it sees
nothing promising in
those talks what do you think it's going
to take
to
force and i'm using the word force here
russia to end this war
unfortunately it looks like it will take
considerably more time
at a minimum you know i think that the
talks if one expected the talks to
suddenly produce peace
that was too high in expectation
so i think it'd be fair to say some
progress was made
particularly on the issue of a neutral
status for ukraine vis-a-vis nato but
the territorial claims
loom the largest
russia appears to be shifting its aims
in the war
uh to
eastern ukraine although
it continues to shell kiev and other
places in the north so we'll have to see
about that
but if russia is indeed refocusing its
campaign on taking land in eastern
ukraine
my sense is that it probably wouldn't be
willing to make any kind of agreement
until it has captured what it deems to
be enough land in order to call
what russia has achieved some kind of
victory for domestic purposes
and calling it a victory i guess will
depend on
vladimir putin calling it a victory
can there be peace
then as long as vladimir putin is in
charge we know that the u.s president's
recent comments they suggest a lot of
exasperation with moscow but
do you think washington has given up any
hope of having a
peace deal while putin is still in power
well unfortunately there probably is no
alternative to making peace with putin
if there will be peace between russia
and ukraine uh there aren't compelling
signs that i see that putin is losing
his grip on power
and in fact sanctions uh can have the
opposite effect so i think it remains
still compelling to pursue a peace
settlement provided there's no
uh undue expectations or
excessive trust which is to say
basically any trust in what uh russian
negotiators may say
um otherwise we're in for
a very long war of attrition uh which
would be deeply unfortunate but usually
it takes a long time for parties to make
peace because both sides have to come to
a recognition
and an acceptance of where they stand
and in this case there are important
international parties as well you
mentioned washington it probably would
require some kind of sanctions relief by
the west in order for there to be a
peace settlement
and before this invasion began there
were weeks
of a flurry of diplomacy and it was
clear then that vladimir putin was only
really interested in talking with the
united states because he considers the
u.s to be an equal is part of the
problem here
that vladimir putin
wants the world particularly washington
to see russia as a superpower
i think those concerns do seem to
resonate with putin given what he says
um
however he has taken the wrong approach
if he wanted to be respected as the head
of a superpower or
or a great power i think it's entirely
possible that had he chosen the path of
a diplomatic resolution to the crisis
back in january
that there would have been some degree
of opening to
reconsider russia's status in the
european security architecture that
conversation was
starting to open
but now there seems to be
no chance
of
vladimir putin being welcomed back into
into the west or being shown respect
it's possible that sanctions could be
lifted but it won't be the kind of
status
that putin perhaps was seeking
and all the while we're seeing
russia move closer and closer to china
the chinese and the russian foreign
ministers
today reaffirmed the two countries
relationship i'm wondering is china
offering any real support to russia
china doesn't seem to be offering
material support to russia and that is
very significant and can get lost in
um some of the uh rhetorical support
that that china has shown uh to russia
in this sense because china is not at
least so far
sending military supplies to russia uh
it is being neutral in the war more so
than countries that are materially
aiding ukraine i don't mean that as a
moral statement since russia's war is
obviously wrong and illegal but china is
trying to walk a line and it does seem
to be complying with western sanctions
though obviously it's not joining in
imposing sanctions itself so china
continues to
try to have its strategic relationship
with russia and also maintain decent
relations with the west that's the
balancing act and it's pretty clear
though that china's principled its
long-standing insistence on respect for
sovereignty and independence and the u.n
charter those have been reduced to lip
service
stephen let me ask you before we run out
of time how worried should europe be
about
u.s commitment particularly to nato
the last polls show
that if there were to be an election
today
former president donald trump would beat
joe biden
well right now joe biden is the
president and i think his commitment to
defending what he calls every inch of
nato territory is very real but you're
absolutely right we have to think down
the line two years five years ten years
and so on and to me it seems like a
gamble to hinge the defense of europe of
of nato
on the united states from far away being
willing to take enormous risks when the
time comes
for the sake of latvia for example so i
think the awakening that is going on in
in europe to its uh responsibilities
that's something to be encouraged but
it's important i think to channel it in
a direction
in which europe can
defend itself uh can have autonomy and
doesn't just seek to renew its
dependence on u.s security protection
stephen murthine with the carnegie
endowment for international peace
stephen we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight valuable context
in this situation thank you
my pleasure
i'm joined by frank ledvig ledwidge he's
a former uk military intelligence
officer he also advised the uk
government on foreign policy and is now
a senior lecturer in strategy and law at
the university of portsmouth
do we have our guest ah there there he
is yeah
the technology is a little tricky with
us tonight frank we appreciate you
joining us you know many have said that
um vladimir putin is aiming to divide
ukraine
um
like the korean peninsula is divided
today you are you wrote though that
ukraine is turning into putin's bleeding
ulcer why do you say that
the reference to bleeding ulcer actually
comes from a couple of hundred years ago
when napoleon was trying to fight the
spanish and portuguese and he put 600
000 people into iberia and about 80 000
came out it was his bleeding ulcer
what
many of us think is going to absolutely
what i think may well happen over the
next uh over the next phase it is that
putin will get into a war that he not
only cannot win but that he can't really
extract himself from and it'll be a sink
into which he'll pour money and material
for for as long as the ukrainians fight
and that's going to be a long time
do you think that vladimir putin knows
exactly
what is going on on the ground in
ukraine in terms of the performance of
his military
it's very difficult to say that it's uh
that his is a closed information system
and even in the western we saw this for
for example in afghanistan with western
generals
not really receiving very good
information and certainly not passing it
up
there are politicians of course who
don't want to hear bad news and putin
may be one of those what we can be sure
of though is that the reports he's get
or the the system is generating will be
fairly accurate from the fsb across to
the military intelligence whether it's
percolating upwards those you just
hinted that very different question
very difficult to know i'm wondering
frank how good is our intelligence i
mean would you
consider the rapid collapse of the
afghan
army after the u.s withdrawal last year
the inability of russia to quickly take
keeve i mean we're in week five now of
this invasion on both of these accounts
western intelligence got it wrong
western intelligence i would assess
actually as being very very good
by and large with respect to ukraine
and it's one element of the war that not
surprisingly particularly the western
contribution to it's really not been
talked about as we speak there are
western intelligence gathering aircraft
in the air to the west and north of
ukraine sucking up all these signals
intelligence they can peering into the
into the into the fog of war there not
only that of course but we've got we've
got other kinds of assets and we have an
ally or rather
the yes and allied the excellent
ukrainian military intelligence service
so overall strategic assessments i think
have been quite good it's very difficult
as you've hinted though to get some
ground truth particularly because
because both sides are pumping out
information that might sometimes be
categorized on both sides as propaganda
yeah that's a very good point to make
and that leads me then to the situation
we're in tonight you know 24 hours ago
there was talk the the deputy russian
defense minister saying that there was
going to be a dramatic reduction in
military activity around the the capital
kiev
and last night there were air raid
sirens across the city there have been
more attacks today i mean the words and
the deeds
when it comes to the russian military
they just don't match
well that certainly appears to be the
case what may be happening is that
there's what's called a fighting
withdrawal going on withdrawing in
combat is a very difficult military
activity to carry out i suspect that the
artillery barrages that matthias was
referring to earlier and that we've
heard about before
may be covering something of a
redeployment driven by military
realities and certainly at least one
battalion group which is about a
thousand people have been redeployed out
of the country as far as we know that's
likely to continue as the russians go on
to the defensive in the north which as
i said before that's a military reality
they've essentially been fought off
there
frank ludwig with the university of
portsmouth frank we appreciate your time
and your valuable analysis tonight thank
you
my pleasure